meine Damen und Herren herzlich
willkommen bei WWM wer weiß mehr dem
wahnsinnsquiz hier auf
[Musik]
klicksu und unser heutiger Gast ist
Summerjam herzlich willkommen hallo
hallo pass auf und du weißt um welches
Thema es heute geht nee nein du weißt es
nicht ich verrate es dir um Summerjam
hmer so ein Quiz zum Thema Summerjam mit
Summerjam das ist kaum zu toppen aber
die Fragen die wir rausgesucht haben
sind so dass du sie möglichst nicht
beantworten kannst also nicht ganz
einfach okay du hast dich aber natürlich
hervorragend vorbereitet dein ganzes
Leben hat sich auf dieses Quiz
vorbereitet genau weil du im Prinzip
alles erlebt hast wonach wir Fragen mehr
oder weniger steigen wir mit der ersten
Frage ein du kommst ja
aus möncheneng Gladbach reit genau darum
dreht sich jetzt die erste Frage gar
kein Problem das weiß ich
nicht also Konzentration die erste Frage
wann wurde reit ein Stadtteil von
möncheng Gladbach boah jetzt hast du
mich warte mal pass auf a
1965 B
1971 C 1975 oder D
1990 warte sage ich Dir jetzt sage ich
Dir jetzt wenn du mir das sagst dann
1975 Fall ich vom Glauben ab das heißt
du würdest 10 1975 einloggen also es
entweder 1990 oder 1975 vorher kann es
nicht sein wenn es 1990 gewesen wä
hättest du ja quasi an so
Feierlichkeiten oder irgendwas
teilnehmen müssen nee es ist 1975 okay
er logt C 1975 ein und das ist richtig
aber
Wahnsinn gerade bei der Frage hätte ich
gedacht Lokalpatriot ich bin bin okay
also es sieht mal wieder so aus als ob
wir den seltenen Fall haben dass einer
wirklich einiges weiß okay wir kommen
zur nächsten
Frage ich hoffe sie schwierig genug ich
zweifel langsam daran wie viel
Produzenten haben für dein Album suchuk
und champagna laut Nennung in der
treckliste
produziert dann
doch n genau das das Problem
A8 B9 C10 oder
D11 ich sag 8
A8 B9 C10 oder D11 wären die Auswahlen
gewesen nimmst aber A8 das logst du
jetzt ein lass mich malch ganz kurz
überlegen ganz kurz eine
Sekunde weil ich sag dir was das Ding
ist ich komme nämlich gerade nur auf s
okay und S hast du aber nicht als
Antwort deshalb denke ich mir a müsste
eigentlich richtig
denk ich meine alle Tracks also es gibt
ja da Bonus und hast du nicht gesehen
und iTunes wobei der tut glaube ich
nichts zur Sache ob der noch dazu
kommt schon zi plus die D sind F also
laut Tracklist da sind ja teilweise auch
Tracks die von zwei Leuten produziert
worden sind ach muss ich die dann auch
doppelt zählen nein nein doppelt nicht
zählen nein nein nein nein nur jeder
zählt nur einmal
okay ich bleib trotzdem bei a du bleibst
trotzdem bei a du wirst wirklich ein ja
GZ sicher ganz sicher gut er lockt das
wird jetzt wahrscheinlich ein
Riesenstreit hier geben ein riesen ein
reieson beef wie man sagt in der Rapper
Branche also du logst A8 ein und das ist
leider falsch und jetzt wird er mich mE
besser SPT ich sag dir die Namen
1 Big Daddy Shane ja 2 ilkan ja 3 prody
Cham ja 4 Judi oh ja
okay Mann er hat auch noch so ein geilen
Song gemacht krass Alter fünf bris
Finger bris Fingers genau brisk Fingers
B cas Fader Gladiator CD Beats oder K
Beats und OS oder
Oz krass es sind neun
krass sorry Leute nicht sauer sein
ich also leider das schon mal ah ich
habe doch wieder gute Hoffnung dass du
okay auch bei der nächsten Frage
scheiterst okay wen wir sehen
chuldig laut deinem MySpace
Profil MySpace was war
das bist du wie alt
A1 B23 C25 oder d29
23 bist du ganz sicher ich glaube schon
23 muss se du würdest B einloggen B
würde ich einloggen und das ist richtig
hammer sensationell also doch gar nicht
so schwer abgelost ja nee Hammer so pass
auf und deshalb gibt's was und
zwar den klicksom Stern darf ich ihn dir
verleihen ja natürlich sensationell
[Musik]
Hammer